corindiak no dirigirá a la selección
francesa en la Copa del Mundo de fútbol
femenino el comité ejecutivo de la
federación francesa ha decidido
destituir a la seleccionadora tras una
disputa pública en la que se han visto
implicadas varias de las principales
jugadoras del equipo
también a nivel de la supervisión del
equipo de Francia en la relación con los
clubes la dirección había un cierto
número de fallos porque constatamos que
entre la experiencia de un cierto número
de jugadoras que se desempeñan en
grandes clubes en Francia o en el
extranjero que están acostumbradas a un
cierto número de estándares de
profesionalismo el equipo de Francia no
estaba hoy en día al nivel de dichos
estándares
había estado en el cargo desde 2017 y
hasta este miércoles todavía Estaba
dispuesta a continuar en vista del
vergonzoso estallido mediático de los
últimos días Deseo no obstante reafirmar
que estoy plenamente comprometida a
llevar a cabo la misión y sobre todo
hacer que Francia se sienta orgullosa
durante el próximo mundial la crisis
estuvo en secreto durante mucho tiempo
hasta que el 24 de febrero Wendy regar
capitana del equipo anunció según
algunas filtraciones que no jugaría con
Francia mientras se mantuviera a
corindiak como seleccionadora otras dos
jugadoras Marian tuanet kato y candidato
diani del París Saint Germain siguieron
el mismo camino señalando con el dedo a
la dirección del conjunto
diac se convirtió en 2014 la primera
mujer en entrenar a un equipo de fútbol
profesional masculino cuando fue
nombrada responsable del Clash de la
liga francesa